thanks to curiosity stream for
supporting this episode C to
curiositystream.com microcosmos to start
streaming thousands of documentaries and
non-fiction TV
shows this frontonia is swimming in a
Minefield we can't see all the dangers
it's evading but abruptly the frontonia
stops and then very very slowly begins
to expand out word in this moment the
fonia's entire body seems to shift away
from its Placid demeanor gone is the
swimming organism now we have something
more strained it's like when a cat is
staring off into the distance with every
muscle tensed and every bit of fur
standing on end you know just by looking
that something is causing distress but
the source of the terror is
invisible but still
you keep looking because you want to
know you have to know what has frozen
this creature in alarm and why is it
reacting this
[Music]
way the homo loan we're watching right
now has a lot in common with the front
Ona we were just observing like
frontonia and most of the organisms
we'll be talking about today the homoo
is ayate a single- celled organism
marked by the hair-like structures
around its body but this homoo isn't
dealing with invisible threats it is the
threat on the hunt for food and when it
comes across this other ciliate a parium
the homoo has an invisible weapon to
help bring down its prey but instead the
homoo flinches from the parami as if it
has been stung because in a sense it has
been what we just watched unfold is a
battle between extrusomes a type of
vesicle found within single- celled
organisms within the cell extrusomes
usually take on crystal-like structures
or are housed in capsules but as we'll
see in a bit when the time comes to be
used extrusive can be quite dramatic to
watch in action what I've just told you
doesn't really reveal much about an
extrusome though is it an attack a
defense something else
entirely yes but more specifically it
depends think of extrusomes sort of like
a knife it can be a weapon sure but it
can also be used to feed or to craft it
all depends on the nature of the blade
and the person wielding it which is to
say that there are a lot of different
types of knives in the world and also
there are many types of extrusomes and
while we cannot provide an exhaustive
display of all of the extrusomes known
to scientists right now we can at least
observe a few of
them let's start with the extrusome
wielded by our hungry homeloan from
earlier which is called a toxic because
it is loaded with toxins we've seen
toxic ists in action in various ciliates
throughout our journey through the
microcosmos and perhaps our best view
has come from the dileptus all along
that trunk-like structure are hundreds
of toxics and as the dileptus hunts for
food it sweeps its trunk from side to
side so that any prey that comes in
contact with the trunk will also come in
contact with those toxic ists for the
ciliates that have them the main task of
of toxic ists is to help catch prey when
not in use they are stored neatly within
capsules lying in weight but should an
unsuspecting meal come too close
Predators like this lacaria will extend
their toxics out from their body and
towards their prey to paralyze it but
look different Predators have different
needs so their toxic ists may look
different and be wielded differently
some organisms might rely more on the
par itic activity of the toxins While
others use the toxics to physically hold
on to their prey there are also
extrusomes that are similar to toxics
but not quite similar enough to be
grouped with them like rabd deists
rod-shaped extrusomes found on Caro
relied ciliates like this Trelos cerid
that shoot like arrows into their prey
and then there are suctorian which look
very unassuming here they're the round
bodies stick out from a stock in the
middle of your screen right now as we
change our perspective though we can
start to make out the tentacles lining
their bodies and among those tentacles
are extrusomes called haptics which have
a Round Knob at the end as unthreatening
as suctorian appear those haptics were
able to grab a hold of some unsuspecting
creature that got too close not only
were the haptics able to puncture the
prey's body they were able to act as a
highway back to their Predator creating
a connection that ultimately feeds the
suctorian but as we saw earlier the
homoo wielded a toxic IST against the
parium but the parium also had the
ability to fight back the parium relied
on a set of extrusomes called trick
assists in this clip James our master of
microscopes has added some diluted ethyl
alcohol onto a slide the paramia are
trying to huddle in the pockets of water
where there's less alcohol but as they
come in contact with more and more of
the alcohol they begin to release their
trick assists it might be a little
difficult to see but up close with some
patience and the careful eye you might
be able to see it better ignore the
bubbles that are emerging from the edge
of the parami apparently that's
something that can just happen as a
parium sits on the side for a while but
look around them at the long threads
emerging from the side of the parium
which seem to overwhelm the ciliate
parium and their tryss are perhaps the
best studied extrusomes among all
ciliates unlike toxics which are usually
localized to one part of the Predator's
body trysts are usually found throughout
the length of the organism's body but
they do have special docking sites that
keep the Tracy situated right below the
plasma membrane
when a stimulus like a predator or
alcohol comes along the membrane of the
tryst will begin to fuse with the parium
membrane creating an opening from which
the Tracy can discharge while parium
have the best characterized Tracy of all
other species do have Tracy as well
including the frontonia we showed you in
the beginning of this episode in fact we
saw them in action set off by the
cleaning Les that James had added to the
water he repeated this multiple times
adding drops of this invisible danger so
we can observe the frontonia TR assists
again and again you can see how the cell
stops and seems instantaneously
surrounded by a mass of thin threads
similar in structure to the parium Tracy
we saw earlier the extrusomes we've
talked about so far have clear roles in
the eternal battle between predator and
prey some defend some attack but some
extrusomes have a murkier purpose like
mucus ists we're showing them here in
ugina which are felet but they're also
found in ciliates as well like
loxophyllum they might be a way to get
food helping their organisms create a
sticky cell surface that acts as a trap
but they might also be a way to help the
organism build a cyst a tool for
movement they EX purpose remains unclear
and who knows maybe they have a range of
uses and with so many more types of
extrusomes that exist in the ciliate
world there are so many opportunities
for us to understand more how these
organisms interact with the world around
them these are all organel perched along
the borders an expression of hunger or a
demand for protection or something more
mysterious waiting for a signal that
says it's their time to eject out into
the
world thank you for coming on this
journey with us as we explore the Unseen
World that surrounds us this episode has
been brought to you by curiosity stream
a subscription streaming service that
offers thousands of documentaries and
non-fiction TV shows from some of the
world's best filmmakers including
award-winning exclusives and Originals
they cover topics like history teach
science food technology travel and more
and to round out our month of creepy
things we're going to recommend checking
out the beasts of Halloween on curiosity
stream not only is it seasonally
appropriate and a bit creepy but it's
also educational you'll dive into the
world of superstitions and traditions
and learn about the many animal species
that have become symbolic with the scary
and Supernatural you can stream
curiosity streams Library including
their collections of curated programs
hand picked by their experts to any
device for viewing anytime anywhere and
if you go to curiositystream.com
microcosmos and use the code microcosmos
to sign up you'll get 25% off for an
entire
year the people on the screen right now
they are our patreon patrons they're the
people who make it all happen here at
Journey to the microcosmos the only
reason this show exists is because
people want it to and these are some of
those people if you'd like to see your
name added to this list and you know I
certainly would you can go to
patreon.com journeyto micro if you want
to see more from our master of
microscopes James Weiss you can check
out jam and germs on Instagram and if
you want to see more from us there's
probably a subscribe button somewhere
[Music]
nearby